uh no I know but this Pearl's World
Pearl's World okay uh we're gonna round
third and head for home I want to talk
to you about this this is something we
hear a lot about emotional intelligence
right emotional intelligence you've
heard girls talk about emotional
intelligence what is what is the modern
woman's definition of emotional
intelligence and then what is pearls oh
God I I don't even know what their
definition is it's like they want I got
to be more vulnerable with them yes
that's it that's what I was getting to
and my definition is I don't know some
[ __ ] feminists say that's
but like honestly they say they want
guys to be more vulnerable but they're
they're talking about the guys that they
want yes right you're talking about like
the five percent of guys that are like
maybe it would be nice if he opened up
to [ __ ] later like they think a little
bit right a little they're like oh he's
kind of he's kind of rude all the time
but I love it and I love it and he does
have a soft side that I only see yeah
yeah and so that's who they're talking
about but I'm like well what about your
friend zone you're they're vulnerable
with you all the time yeah all the time
they cry to you about their moms their
ex-girlfriends the other girl's friend
zoning them are you [ __ ] those guys
yeah the answer is no it doesn't make
any sense for men to be to be openly
vulnerable to women on purpose it makes
absolutely no sense and and I'm not I'm
going through quite a bit I'm going
through a lot right now with some of my
friends and family Devin has them she
knows him nothing about I've told her
bits and pieces of it here and there I'm
like yeah something's going on with my
sister blah blah blah I don't talk to
her about that I talk I've talked to
I've talked to Myron I've talked to AMS
and I've talked to Kevin Sabo those are
the guys that I bent my spleen to in
terms of how to handle these situations
the reason why I can't I cannot tell
Devin what I'm feeling about these
things is because she's counting on me
to be the emotional Rock and if if she
can't count on me to be the emotional
Rock then who can she count on that's
why you keep this [ __ ] to yourself Devin
do you ever get nosy
uh no oh okay I was just wondering um if
I really want to know something I'll
just ask if he wants me to know he'll
tell me
um again being nosy what am I gonna do
go through his phone like that's creepy
do you ever just like ask again or
anything or you just ask around no no so
like if he if he if you can see
something's like bothering him and and
you're like oh what's wrong and he's
like oh just something with my sister do
you ever ask again because you're
curious or no if I see something as
distressing him then I will I will just
let him know hey I'm here for you if you
feel like talking but I'm not gonna be
pushy I'm not gonna nag him to tell me
something that he's not ready to open up
about maybe what do you think like we
could have Devin do conflict resolution
and wife School god dude I'm actually
pretty good at de-escalating things
because I hate I hate conflict so in
confrontations I'm an expert at avoiding
it Bobs and weaves like Floyd Mayweather
like this is why her and I we work so
well together because I am highly highly
confrontational she's not trying to
argue or fight with anybody or anything
number one number two she's very good at
um because you know I'm a high octane
Guy and um and she's very good at uh
she's very good at calming me down it's
almost like uh it's almost like and I
[ __ ] hate these the the Black Widow
character how she seems to have this
have this effect on the Hulk even when
he's she can sort of you know she rubs
his hand hey big guy the sun's getting
low blah blah blah and then he calms
down Devin is very very good at that
she's had lots of practice
um so I guess uh I guess the final final
question is do you believe uh do you
think
do you think when do you think relations
because relations between men and women
have never been worse
um men don't trust women women don't
trust men is there an end in sight is it
going to happen in our in our lifetime
or are American men just gonna be like
you know what I'm throwing my hands up
I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] my sex doll or
I'm gonna go to Southeast Asia and I'm
leaving women alone I think when you
start to see the benefits rolling I
think at some point the government's
going to run out of money yeah and I
think once we start to see I think women
are very opportunistic yes and I think
as soon as you start to see like the
benefits rolling back that's when you'll
see women running to their friend zone
there you go please marry me please here
you go
um and you know um I I do think
like unfortunately like for the guys
like I I do think guys will take them so
yeah yeah well because because of the
lack of options uh Andrew Tate uh once
said and this was a hundred percent true
the poorer a country is the closer they
the closer they align with traditional
gender roles yeah feminism is a first
world problem and I don't I don't think
feminism is never not going to be a
problem in the United States the only
thing that could probably stop it or
slow it down is if we become a maybe
actually we don't even have to become a
third world we can become a second world
country I don't know if there's any such
thing a second world country is
something like Ukraine used to be
um what's another second world country
they're not rich but they're not poor
India is probably kind of a second world
country
um and we we got a good example we got a
good example of that during covid how
many dude [ __ ] did not know what the
[ __ ] to do [ __ ] was like oh my God it's
covid I need a man that was the closest
we ever came to experience maybe second
and third world problems now that we're
out of it we're back to many [ __ ] I
don't need a man yeah I think as soon I
think life humbles people
consequences
if it's not right away and I do think
when women
I start to see how I might be homeless
they're like
I think it might be about that time yeah
my lease is up and uh getting kicked out
and yeah I know I've friendzoned you for
10 years but I'm ready I'm ready and
Johnny's like okay
maybe and her at 38. oh my God Jesus
Christ yeah he'll have awesome and you
know who knows uh who knows whatever
else uh Pearl this was fun this is so
fun yeah this was a lot of fun uh we're
actually coming out to uh England
January February yeah somewhere around
there uh that's gonna be a lot of fun
um your guests go ahead I'm trying to
get a bunch of you to come out yeah I
want to do like a little round table or
something I would love nothing more than
to go toe-to-toe with these [ __ ] on
your show yeah that would be absolutely
that would be oh my God I'm licking my
every once in a while I'll get fresh and
fit withdrawal you know what I mean like
oh like I think I was on fresh and fit
last month and I'm good for a while but
now I'm like damn I want to yell at
these [ __ ] [ __ ] man like yo Myron
man uh I'm fly down next week man set me
up for after hours he's like all right
bed I know I know I've been too good
when you get the it's just start yelling
at somebody because you haven't been
yelling at me so
it doesn't give me a reason too yeah you
want me to be annoying or you know pop
off on you just so you can get out of
your system I'll come up with something
for you that's quite all right no I
would I would very much appreciate if
you did not become annoying on purpose
that would be that would be that would
that would that would be good
I'm I'm I I think yeah pretty pretty
pretty sure about that uh we are gonna
go I don't know where we're gonna go eat
at I'm not gonna say it because some
crazy [ __ ] might show up and
then I might end in jail
um
let me see if we have any other any
other super chats
um so uh guys subscribe to her Channel
it is uh just pearly things uh yeah guys
I've been banned on Instagram I lost my
Instagram account as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible